do in this video is think about
multiplying our strategies for
multiplying numbers that are expressed
in terms of hundreds or thousands or
tens and so we see an example right over
here we have 800 times 400. now like
always i encourage you to pause this
video and see if you can work this out
on your own
now let's work this
through together and i'm going to work
it out in a way that at least my head
likes to tackle it and once you get
enough practice you might even be able
to do these types of multiplication
problems without even needing to use
paper
so the key realization here is to say
well look this is eight hundreds
so that's the same thing as eight
times one hundred
and
this over here is four hundreds so this
is four
times
one hundred and so it's eight times one
hundred times four times one
and if you're multiplying a bunch of
numbers like this you can switch the
order in which you're doing the
multiplication so you can view this
as 8
times 4
8 times 4
times 100 times 100
times 100
now why is this easier
well what is 8 times 4 going to be
well 8 times 4 if we know our times
tables is 32
and so it's going to be 32
times what's a hundred times 100 going
to be
now there's multiple ways that you could
think about this and i want you to
really think it through but we'll soon
see that there's a fairly fast way of
making sure we got it right
but one way to think about it is
well let me do it over here 10
times 100 is equal to
a thousand and so a hundred times a
hundred is going to be ten times that or
it's going to be equal to
ten thousand
so
this stuff right over here is equal to
000. now you might notice something
interesting here i have
two zeros and then another two zeros so
i have a total of four zeros and then i
have four zeros here because every time
if you multi every time you multiply by
10 you're going to add another zero so
if you're multiplying by 100 you're
going to add two zeros if you're at
multiplying by a thousand you're going
to add three zeros and you see that here
so you have 32 times 10 000 which is
going to be cut b what
well let's see 32
times a thousand would be 32 000 but
this is 32 times 10 000. so it's going
to be 320
000.
now you might already notice an
interesting pattern here 32 times 1
followed by four zeros is 32 followed by
four zeros this is 32 ten thousands
which is third three hundred and twenty
thousand now another way you could have
thought about it is
eight
times four
gives us our thirty-two
and then we have
two zeros there two zeros there for a
total of four zeros and we have our four
zeros right over there now i don't want
you to just memorize that it works
because this is eight hundreds times
four hundreds eight times four gives us
the 32 and then the 100 times the
hundreds that's where these four zeros
come from
let's do
another example
so let's do
let me delete this
and let us do let me get my pen back
so let's do
times 70
30 or let's do 30 times 700 pause the
video and see if you can figure this out
so we can do it like we did before 30 is
3 times 10
so times 700 which is 7
times 100
and so if you say 3 times 7 is going to
be 21
times
10 times 100 is going to be a thousand
so what's 21 times a thousand well
that's going to be 21
000. now just like we saw before
you'll once you get a hang of it and i
always want you to understand where it's
coming from
3 times 7 is the 21 and then you're
going to multiply that times
10 and then 100. so you have one two
three zeros one two three zeros
let's do one more of these
so let's say we wanted to multiply
two thousand
times eight thousand pause the video and
see if you can figure out what this is
maybe in your head try to do this one in
your head or on paper don't feel bad if
you need to use paper that's always
prudent
well you might get the hang of it now
you might be able to do this quite
quickly you might be able to say hey 2
times 8 well that's going to be equal to
and then i have
and then i have three
plus three zeros so that's going to be
six zeros one two three four five six
which gives me 16 million and you would
absolutely be correct
now i wanna reinforce what you're doing
when you're just counting zeros like
that
what you're doing is you're saying hey
this is the same thing as two times one
thousand
times eight times one thousand
eight times
one thousand and then you're just
changing the order of multiplication
you're saying hey let me multiply the
two
and the eight
you multiply the two times the eight and
you get sixteen and then you multiply
the times a thousand times a thousand so
times
a thousand
times a thousand
and a thousand to thousands
that's one million this is one million
right over here
and notice you see it there too a
thousand times a thousand you have three
zeros three zeros you get six zeros a
thousand thousands is a million sixteen
times a million
is sixteen million so hopefully that
helps and makes you a little bit more
comfortable multiplying these numbers
that are multiples of ten hundred
thousands even millions